all right so you
the movement of the workshop was
changing my mind about things but
certainly in the direction of sharpening
ideas I had about things very much in a
very important way one of the
pre-existing ideas I had coming in was
that it's always fun to bring smart
interesting people into the same room
and good things happen that you don't
predict and that was absolutely verified
so thanks everyone for participating in
that um I guess the other the major idea
about naturalism and sort of the idea I
have belt naturalism moving forward BA
naturalism itself rather than all the
Disciplinary interests is the idea that
there is one world the natural world but
there are many ways of talking about
that natural world and it's
understanding the many ways of talking
about and how they fit together and are
very far than they're useful or rejected
that is the important part of the
program so I can't resist mentioning one
of the papers that was foundational for
my understanding of thinking about
layers and emergence and things like
that was by Sidney Coleman who taught
Janna and me quantum field theory many
years ago in 1975 he wrote a paper
called quantum sign Gordon equation as
the massive Turing model anyone else had
this at their favorite paper so it's
about keycap he finds a model theory in
one dimension of space one dimension of
time and it's actually two theories
there's a theory called the quantum sign
Gordon equation which is just a terrible
terrible term that he used as a joke and
then caught on we have a boson since
we're going back to bosons and fermions
there's a boson in a particular
potential and the potential is just a
sine wave it goes up and again and
there's a whole nother theory which is a
theory of fermions also in one spatial
dimension where these fermions can bump
into each other and interact and what
coleman shows in and that utterly
independently written series one theory
bosons one theory fermions and Coleman
proves mathematically that there
secretly the same exact theory that in
this boson Theory not only have little
oscillations in the potential which
looked like bosons but you also have big
variations which go from one minimum to
another and they act like four
and you crank up the coupling constant
and you show that every thing that you
can calculate in one theory is exactly
the same as you would get from doing it
in the other theory so here is one
reality with two very very different
ontology that are equivalent in every
possible way so that liberated my
thinking about the right way to think
about reality in that it made me think
that different ways of talking about the
same underlying reality are just as good
and I would say that's even true if
they're not equivalent if like
thermodynamics is a subset of the domain
of applicability of the atomic theory
that underlies it but nevertheless my
own personal view be that the concepts
of thermodynamics are equally real and
equally part of how to talk about things
and so I would say the same thing about
whatever it is we call volition or
freewill I'm kind of getting sympathetic
to the idea that freewill has too many
barnacles I think that an interesting
idea but nevertheless so even if you buy
all that of the ways that we have of
talking about the natural world there
are two different species there are the
sort of descriptive vocabularies and
there are the normative vocabularies and
I think they're both important but I
think that the ways that we have of
talking about them and validating them
are very different and that's something
we didn't quite get into talking about
at a very specific level but I think
that both the parallelism is important
and the differences are important I
think that when we decide what is moral
what is right or what is aesthetically
beautiful or what is artistic these are
all vocabularies for talking about the
world but in those normative spheres we
don't have recourse to the simple and
and consensus scientific apparatus that
we have for the descriptive ones so we
have contention and I think then act I
was surprised that there seem to be so
much potential common ground when we
were talking about morale
that we all have impulses in us and
we're all gonna have to use some
communicative process to work out how to
develop that into a theory of morality
so one conclusion of the workshop for me
is that I'm even more optimistic about
naturalism than I was before and I would
even say that not only academically but
also publicly I think that you know I
see a way forward to making this a
compelling story to tell people I don't
think we have the vocabulary in the
rhetoric to do it yet I don't think we
have the social aspects that we all
agree are important but I see no
obstacles in the way to do that and you
know 100 years from now and that's when
everyone is a naturalist they will look
back and go yes there was that moment in
Stockbridge when it all got off the
ground
you